[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
happy Friday everybody you look amazing
delicious crowd tonight
and as usual because it's Friday let's
welcome tonight's guests of all the
jesuses I know he's the hotepiest social
scientists and YouTube host Otep Jesus
she's from Denver but gets high owning
the libs editor-in-chief of the
Federalist Molly Hemingway
[Applause]
like a speed bump it's always best to
avoid her Fox News contributor captive
[Applause]
and his fights are more lopsided than
Kathy hogle's eyebrows my massive
sidekick in the NWA World Heavyweight
Champion
[Applause]
all right before we get to some news
stories it's Friday so let's do this
[Music]
Mmm Yeah it's leftovers where I read the
jokes we didn't use this week and as
always it's my first time reading these
so if they suck we all go out into the
parking lot we beat the crap out of a
writer
here we go on Thursday President Biden
took a spill after delivering a
commencement speech at the U.S Air Force
Academy the White House says he's fine
he just tripped over an old sandbag
oh
Jeff Bezos and Lauren Sanchez are
reportedly spending 600 Grand a month to
rent Kenny G's empty Malibu home
amenities include a pool a screening
room and best of all no Kenny G
[Laughter]
or a guy after 79 year old Robert De
Niro welcomed his his seventh child
fellow Godfather or Star Al Pacino
announced he's expecting his fourth
child at the age of 83.
so your move Diane Keaton
[Laughter]
meanwhile a DNA test confirmed that
Pacino is in fact the child's
grandfather
[Laughter]
that's funny
because it can't happen it's not
physically possible and you know it's
going to be awkward when that kid gets
old enough to borrow the car Jesus
you don't see that those many that many
hearses anymore anyway 80s pop star
Tiffany was involved in a serious
accident when a tire from a truck rolled
across a highway and collided with her
car but she says she's fine and relieved
to finally experience a second hit
[Laughter]
Korean Tyrant Kim jong-un's weight has
reportedly ballooned to more than 300
pounds in fact he's so fat he's changing
his pronouns to they
singer lizzo says she's close to
quitting music because of all the
negative comments about her weight but
some of her fans are fine with it
that's pretty funny damn
and if you're blind at home it's a
picture of Stevie Wonder
some irony in that I guess and finally
next week Mike Pence will announce that
he's officially running for president
and you'll have to love his new campaign
slogan build back blander
yeah Symphony Applause
all right now to some news so how was
Donald's Town Hall after Biden said see
you next fall
on the same day Joe Biden worked on his
break dancing at the Air Force Academy
commencement ceremony Trump and Hannity
talked about it during a fox Town Hall
Trump called it a bad fall and got
reminded of a time he could have slipped
walking down a ramp after a West Point
speech of his own I wonder if he had the
general next to him I had the general
next to me the commandant of cadets nice
guy big guy strong guy I said General uh
and he's wearing combat boots they don't
slip too much I said General get ready
because I may have to grab you here
big strong guy I wonder if Trump said
he's not falling I said I'm not falling
there's no way so I'd go Tippy Toe down
the thing that was a mistake because it
didn't look so good I even agree it
wasn't but I got killed and they never
covered that speech I said it was my bed
someday they'll let a hundred years
they're going to put that speech out I I
really but uh you can't fall you just
can't fall no matter what just can't
allow it to happen you can't
you can't be allowed to fall
but Trump then said it's not right to
make fun of Biden's mental acuity I
don't know if he's supposed to say this
well I don't know if I'm supposed to say
this I actually called Sean and I asked
Sean not to joke about it I was joking
because he used to joke about it and I
said honestly I don't think it looks
good for you or for anybody for you to
joke about it because it's a serious
problem
this is the best ever Trump telling
somebody not to make fun of somebody
awesome
is the best we don't deserve him
so why is Trump so interested in taking
the high road well Joe struggles with
the paved Road
I haven't seen this act an act this
classy since Kudlow gave me a lap dance
Trump certainly was never shown the same
courtesy after all of course President
Biden blames his fall on a sandbag but
it wasn't just any sandbag turns out it
was a super Maga extreme Republican one
damn those pesky domestic terrorists
what say you Joe
oh yeah yeah look I hate to agree with
orange man but he's right lay off Old
Joe
uh but besides it's not the mind it's
the problem it's everything to the south
I mean if I sit in a chair for more than
90 seconds I can't feel my legs
but if I close my eyes I'm as old as I
am then fly
look I'll show you okay oh I'm running a
50-yard Dash I'm doing the high jump but
then I open my eyes
I can't feel my legs
arable
all right
Molly
[Applause]
I kind of love this High Road take
because it really is a low road
masquerading as a high road he's like
saying you know this guy's in such bad
shape I don't think we should make fun
of them right it's like blesser you know
I don't know I remember actually after
Ruth Bader Ginsburg died I went on TV
and I was trying to be polite but Donald
Trump totally outclassed me and I was
like okay if you're not doing as well as
Donald Trump you need to you need to
roll it back but it is true everybody
sees what's going on you don't need to
pile on and not to disagree with our
esteemed president but it's not the
physical Falls it's the fact that he
doesn't make sense when he's talking he
doesn't remember people's names that's a
bigger concern yeah you know that's the
thing it's like if you looked at him
from a physical specimen he looks fine
he's actually looks pretty fit
but it it's all the stuff going on in
there which ain't a lot actually yeah
maybe there's like two cells fighting
over a piece of shrimp
that's the thing that worries me hotep
do you think it should be off limits to
talk about is stumbling and as
embarrassing Behavior I Gotta Give it to
Trump I'm actually very surprised at
that take uh and I'm proud of him that
he he did that however me on the other
hand you know
uh Jim Crow Joe
crime Bill Joe
karma's a and he can kiss my black
ass
can you give Biden some credit and that
even though he falls a lot he still gets
up
[Laughter]
I don't even know how he's operating I
want I want whatever drugs they're
giving him because the fact that he's
still operating as president is one
surprising too scary because it's like
we know he's not doing a job so who's
actually doing the job exactly yeah
that's the scary part for me but I just
don't understand how he's still doing it
and I don't understand how they're gonna
run him again this is abuse against
elderly people yeah let's just call it
what it is yeah usually you take away
the the uh the car keys but they should
take the house keys from Joe
cat you think it's unfair uh and mean to
make these jokes do you think Donald
Trump is on to something that it's
basically kicking a man when he's
literally down
keep up with that it was good thank you
I mean I I wrote an entire book about
how it's okay to joke about anything did
you know how is it doing doing very well
yes it's not doing very well yes and uh
but here's the thing I think actually
you kind of alluded to this what Trump
is doing is way more Savage than any
joke about it because he's basically
saying no you can't make fun of it
because this is a very serious sick
situation yes like have you ever been in
a fight with somebody like a verbal
fight with somebody and you you know
what's the meanest thing they can do
rather than something they can say mean
back is like you're being so crazy I'm
not even talking to you right now
like that like now I am filled with the
rage for weeks
um because he's that's ultimately it is
ultimately the more Savage thing and
imagine if he continued this to be like
no I can't I can't even engage because
he's not well yes
I don't feel right I'm sorry that did
you guys all saw this sir are you okay
like do you need anything because I can
tell something's really wrong yes and
maybe you should go to bed and call me
in the morning
nothing Savage nothing is crueler yeah
and more Savage than that yeah he it's
like and nothing is as important as your
health not even this debate I think we
should just not have enough or no the
meanest thing someone I'm worried about
you go yourself
Tyrus you know he blames sandbags uh
uh what does that do to the sandbag
industry you know I'm over here oh I
know
going on oh yeah where am I no but you
think about it it's like sandbags save
millions of lives exactly the
commencement speech was outside of a
hurricane Zone that had sandbags
everywhere
I mean he's still got a little bit
because when he hit the ground he knew
the point at something that wasn't there
yeah so I mean he's still got a little
bit left I mean have you watched its
first thing he did was uh over there I
just love the fact that as a former
Bodyguard the Secret Service is over him
because look at him the Secret Service
is looking at him and he's not helping
him up no he's like this is the sixth
time today I had to do this
that's just everyone else is around this
dude's tired he needs a backyotomy from
picking this dude up one of the things
are what are the things on the bottom of
his shoe is anybody those are the
magnets to keep him from wandering off
the White House has that thing wherever
he gets to the door the metal plate on
there activates stuck because otherwise
you're going to see him walking around
the front yard and stuff and
anyone knows when they gotta watch oh
Uncle Joe the first thing is like who's
watching him I thought you were watching
them then they find him at the
supermarket smelling little kids hair
it's the same thing
it's the same thing like
that secret service man he's just
counting the days bro
[Laughter]
she's even holding the other guy back
nah man nah make him he needs to do it
himself make him do it himself
like you're out and your wife is too
much to drink nah she can get up
two margaritas my ass get up I'm not
helping like this is why I don't take
you nowhere so I think we can all agree
with Donald Trump it's not right
I'm in that kiss my ass line with Jesus
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else